ça fait mal de devoir le dire mais quand
même ça fait 21 ans qu'une équipe
canadienne ne pas gagner la coupe
stanley quand même incroyable maintenant
qu'à des canadiens et canadiennes sur
sept qui est là cette année on a vu hier
dans le premier volet des reportages
josiane survie pourquoi ça se produisait
et on attribue une part du problème à la
mauvaise gestion mais il ya tout un tas
d'autres raisons et on va vous les
montrer que ce soir c'était la dernière
fois qu'il était canadienne soulevé la
co 1993
triste record même si les clubs du pays
pèsent lourd dans l'équation 50% des
revenus de la ligue nationale premier
des sept équipes canadiennes vexé quand
même pas rien et c'est sur les équipes
canadiennes sont des vaches à lait des
couleurs qui font de l'argent mais qui
stagne au deuxième et dernier tiers du
classement de la ligue nationale le
problème des marchés show là
déchaîne les passions
comme les équipes canadiennes sont
tellement coincé entre le désir de
rebâtir et le fardeau du succès qui
vient avec les attentes élevées d'un
marché très chaud là il ya une dualité
qui est très dur c'est la vie parmi les
champions de la coupe stanley depuis 93
une chose saute aux yeux au moins deux
joueurs et les canadiens se sont
illustrés chaque fois sauf en 2008
or les grands joueurs canadiens qui joue
au canada sont rares à sotchi par
exemple ils n'étaient que quatre à
appartenir à des clubs canadiens 4 et
aucun attaquant pourquoi si peu
tellement canadiens ici peut-être la
pression des gros marchés
peut-être aussi le manque d'attrait des
petits marchés pour le joueur
d'exception le choix entre aller jouer à
ottawa calgary ou edmonton où aller
jouer en californie où elle joue à new
york
c'est un des avantages majeurs pour les
équipes canadiennes le dollar canadien
n'a pas aidé le canada non plus il a
frôlé les 60 cents américains
au début des années 2000 donc moins
d'argent pour se payer des vedettes ses
équipes d'arc et 80% ne sont pas de
dépenser les salaires etc les salles à
un bond de 20% seulement à cause du
change
on se retrouve automatiquement dans un
marché inégale entre les équipes
canadiennes américaines puis quand le
dollar regretté la ligue 1 limiter des
dépenses des équipes avec son plafond
salarial en 2005 donc pas moyen d'en
profiter pour les formations canada
l on pourrait peut-être parler de guînes
pour le canada qui a atteint la grande
finale 5 fois depuis 93
or quatre des cinq finales se sont
rendus à la limite sans compter des
nordiques qui sont allés gagner la coupe
l'année suivant leur déménagement au
colorado
décidément vient de s'ouvrir à tous
canada à moorea